[Music]
in failed threat news hmm submitted by
Bart's beastly wifey oh that's cool I am
beastly oh good win own am i I didn't
know how something take it I was already
I thought it was a great cop that's what
I don't know
beastly usually like ugly but yeah like
you know outside or so you be smooth
like it peacefully because they know I
trained so they always call me is
basically yeah I hope this person was
like yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] Gator in
really means are the best view a man
wanted to scare someone with a bomb
threat but completely failed like
there's a bomb just kidding how do you
feel at that yeah how do you feel well
let's do like a room full of chests like
there's a bomb so we all have bombs
anybody that's like I just would call a
mega fail mm-hmm that's how they talk
yeah sounds like God such a fail hashtag
fail yeah you called out a bomb come on
here so that was cute that's another
song yeah so this man named Carrie she's
50 years old he boat repair man he lives
in Houston Texas you got both iOS
oh there's always gonna say well there's
no H in there but yeah it might be like
boat lake repair guy he went on the dark
web and he was looking for a bomb maker
to give him supplies for him to scare a
neighbor and so are you saying is that
he didn't want to kill anyone he just
wanted to send a message
so I he was saying is that you know he
might want to use like some dynamite or
gasoline or diesel fuel and pressure
spray the entire building of where this
neighbor lives and so where he lives
it's kind of like a like a wooden shed
but he uses it as his apartment so he's
he's describing all of this to this
potential wall maker
he lives in the ship the neighbor that
he's trying to get our scary area she
lives in the shed so he's exchanging a
lot of emails with this bomb maker and
they posted out the emails that he was
writing and moves really poorly written
so it says don't know
exactly what's inside but person using
for Department person will not be there
when set off don't want to kill just
send message the idea we have for this
person is while he sleeping we put
grenade in back of truck and run to our
car 20 to 30 metres away he hears truck
blow up and come outside while he
outside we blow up house he writes like
a Chinese man yeah tell me about Rene's
he outside his house we blow up boom
boom boom
tell me about Rene please how far do we
need to be away and so he agreed to pay
$600 for dynamite grenade and a remote
detonator the hella good deal actually
yeah so he was creating this deal and he
spent more than $15,000 on bitcoins
which is like the internet currency
right the country so ball maker sent a
box to like those post office so he
wants to go pick it up and then he took
it back into his home and then that's
when the FBI busted in and said boom
you've been talking to a CIA agent boom
was there GPS in the package I'm not
sure those areas and baggage I just know
that that's because of him obtaining the
package is how the yeah I was able to
track him down because I think is a UPS
driver stealing packages at our central
office and I kind of want to send myself
some expensive looking package with a
GPS something in salute got a look on
the dark web no or you put take a GPS
tracker thing and mail it to yourself
here yeah and then like the Nike boxes
yeah yeah I like what you're doing right
now because you're putting it out there
in a video and so he's gonna be like oh
[ __ ] nah I can still impact pretty good
if he's a fan
I'll be funny not talking that so I
could be try to sell that on eBay he was
arrested for attempting to knowingly
transport across state lines materials
powerful enough to meme and kill people
and to destroy buildings that's what he
was
I was he was like he was arrested for
attempting to prank his brother I got
just holding him cuz I'm gonna [ __ ] up
his car and [ __ ] up his house yeah a
dude on YouTube it's still breaking okay
if they still call it that yes I should
like stand that yeah right yeah I wonder
why he was gonna
like I just want to blow up this car I
don't want to hurt the guy
what's the measure what's the message
you were emphasizing how much he cared
about him though so I'm gonna make sure
do like the full charge you didn't wanna
hurt him don't hurt him just below and
you have a funny imagination though
because he probably imagine him sleeping
in a car was wrong
what was that he goes outside and in his
house plan oh my god like that's no I
think it's like it's like what was that
anyone anyone does anything oh my god my
hospital I get the message
I get it in this cat's head okay that's
what we'll do it it's like because I
don't get the message what's the message
a know they gotta leave like everyone
else does I can't go back to China dude
tell him that man you've gotta live in a
shed so he's gonna destroy my shins guy
man it was like no no but that's not the
guy in a shed it is all the cats on you
I don't know you want to make you the
tree maybe you learn English in China I
don't know what if it was like you give
me bomb I do like maybe there's like
that oh yeah night rise right thing I
don't know what accident it was that
sound it's my dad on TechSmith good give
me bomb give me bomb blow up car yeah I
think I don't know my theory as to why
he was writing so poorly is because he
was using the Onion Router like a tour
so it's like what it does it changes
your IP address to make it undetectable
call tor browser yeah and so uh I know
that Islam same as I know that making
your ice cream so what I think maybe he
thought like you know you can only sign
a certain amount of words per message
that's right maybe how did the FBI track
Almighty give you the onion modem
because you went to pick up the package
Oh
Anala name because they already know
heart that she I'm sorry yes oh because
it's the FBI I feel like all this [ __ ]
was even released by the FBI it's like
here's your secret browser it's like
everyone download secret browser calm
and then it's like it's like
this is very secret now any FBI is like
you idiots we may be happy we made it
yeah that's what I think that dude he
purchased these bought or these like
materials were bombs like with bitcoins
yes you can drink bitcoins now oh you
know that no the fact that people are
actually accepting payment for bitcoins
on its internet currency it's a new
network of us it's really really
valuable really what are you saying all
the computers ate a lemon I know I know
things I just know that there's a
limited amount of bitcoins there's a
finite amount yeah that's what they keep
telling us but then they keep finding
more yeah yeah how does that work
because you have to mine now so like
let's say if there's only a hundred
bitcoins right then it just breaks down
like you could go less than one Bitcoin
so it's like 0.5 bit corner point 3 or
point zero zero for Bitcoin or whatever
thank gold they get harder and harder to
find uh I think it's even more guy oh
yeah I should have bought bitcoins my
mom sells good points for some weird
reason I don't know your mama buys
bitcoins themselves not only trademiner
your mom's a hacker do you claim dealer
I don't know why if you want to
basically buy Bitcoin now by hearing em
do this with them alright that's the new
[ __ ] I didn't know nothing your
investment advice for me a minute video
where's the eyeshadow oh we can't know
anything we can't believe you without
with the normal eyes yeah okay alright
hello he knows everything
there we go that's good tell me the
secret laughter we believe like I don't
want to tell you about my tell you the
secret right now I don't take advice
from an Internet guy I need to do
something where I use my money to make
money
I think it's called investing investing
atheria okay only dumb people and I
really do mean this because I know a lot
of people who don't invest anything and
you're going to end up like every one of
my family did where you just you don't
make your money work for you like this
is we live in a country and in a system
where you're basically if you're not
investing in
[ __ ] that you're [ __ ] up okay and I'm
not saying it's right a Jew a type
graduation' that's not patriotic I think
it is wrong well you know what either
you play the game too or you get left
behind thank you very much that's
awesome because I agree
you know 60% of our economy is a
financial institutions know where you
think the money goes we don't handle
industry oh but I'm gonna stand on
principle because I begin to them it's
like now just look you play the game
yeah fifty percent of our economy is
finance what does that tell you
tells you money making money it's just
profit coming out of nowhere
okay stop brakes I'm gonna put my money
in a room I'm gonna turn the lights on
I'm a sexy [ __ ] shade of light I'm up
on some sexy Barry White music and my
money's no [ __ ] and have kids and then
that much energy yet for me and we're
just hanging out well yeah you never get
it for me I just want money to have kids
you put your money in everyone and
they'd be back they jump out a window
but a bernie madoffs table book Rich Dad
Poor Dad I did long time ago but then so
many other people read it too and enough
everyone said the market is not
everything saturate I got to do some
different [ __ ] now no but he died just
like the message that you have to invest
in something like he chose realistic yes
to myself how's their ROI on that you're
gonna take a while yeah and we die very
poor he keep saying [ __ ] like that I
invested in myself and look what it got
me
I am a hoarder this is man you know I
have a [ __ ] three-bedroom house and
it's worth less than when I bought it
whoo but I got another baby on the way
all right exactly
I don't know but please somebody out
there if you guys understand in your old
money
teach me tell me your secret bring me
into your society the [ __ ] Illuminati
please I want to learn all the money
they were probably just born into it
like where their money is working so
much like from the older generations
they don't even know how they got it
it's just they have it and it just keeps
working and they're just living off
interest forever can you teach me livin
off
questions and their kids going on I know
we got fans now watch this stuff that's
their old money like you guys come on
man let's just let's have a meet and
greet
we're just inviting the Bohemian freakin
Grove you'd help us box yeah I want to
pray to a ow I want to meet Beyonce I
want to jerk off in a bucket with
everyone else working often but yeah and
then have a ritual and then cut my
wrists a little bit like a little sliver
of it and have the blood drip out in the
bucket and then I jerk off wanna yep and
then Blood Brothers know with George W
Bush you're gonna take his last name I
love your hat hope you're ready let's go
Bohemian Grove want just get I want to
be in this elite circle please hello
amount of people do you want to contact
me and everybody else you see go ahead
and check the description box below and
follow our social medias instagrams and
Twitter's for more videos click up there
baby
[Music]